now to some potentially encouraging news
for parents who have struggled to find
baby formula months after the fda shut
down an abbott plant in michigan that
factory has been cleared to reopen
however it could take weeks to restart
production and get formula back on
shelves and there are still many
questions about the biden
administration's response to this crisis
ed o'keefe is at the white house for us
ed good morning to you tony good to see
you that michigan plant was shut down in
february when the company had to begin
recalling product and since then more
than 40 percent of formula has gone
missing off of shelves at major
retailers across the country quite a
shortage so now under an agreement with
the fda abbott can begin the process of
reopening once the agency approves the
initial steps abbott says the factory
can be completely up and running within
two weeks but it would be another six to
eight weeks before formula is back on
the shelves nobody is setting a
definitive date the government or the
company at the fda but if you do the
math it seems the earliest the baby
formula supply would be back to normal
is at least mid-july
the fda also plans to relax some
regulations to allow more formula to be
imported into the united states to boost
supply meantime lawmakers in both
parties among them new york democratic
senator kirsten gillibrand are calling
on president biden to use the defense
production act to compel other companies
to help produce more formula that was
the same law that was used to boost
production of ventilators and other
supplies at the beginning of the
pandemic the white house says it's one
of many options still under
consideration the fda commissioner will
testify on capitol hill later this week
he's likely to face all sorts of
questions including why his agency
waited so long to reopen that michigan
plant given that an investigation found
that the illness traced to this formula
was never actually found at that
facility
nate
ed thank you